phew look this is ah this is all this is
everyone's childhood this is whoever
everyone who worked on this show your
your wardrobe team got this together
with like a day or two notice they're
amazing you know why because they're
amazing we're dressing for the 80s today
and this is literally
top three characters of all time for me
especially for my childhood labyrinth
david bowie it was amazing they
mentioned that that this is your
favorite movie well first of all this is
how i dress first of all so and they
were like and i was like what's
labyrinth this is me um
it's just a monday
what it's really all about the eyebrows
it's the pointy eyebrow it's amazing i
mean you're about to just break out and
babe with the power it's going to be
amazing did you love the movie as well i
did i remember the first time i saw it
and i was titillated and disturbed
because it's they're like it's so like
toby like they're kind of scary like a
lot of it's like very scary yeah they're
horrifying yeah it it's what i love
about henson
henson doesn't talk down never talk down
to kids they always assume the best of
children even when they're making
terrifying stuff yeah and so i was
terrified and then you see david bowie
in that movie and i was a kid and i was
like what am i feeling here i'm feeling
something but i didn't know what was he
feeling there because his pants
do we think that was him or was that
like a cup we'll talk about it i'm just
saying
like for a child you were like it looks
like a wrestler like it look it look it
looked like a lot happening down there
and yeah yeah but he would confuse me
about yeah i looked at that big bulge
and i was like wait what is the male
anatomy then
why don't i have that is it one circle
[Laughter]
it was amazing
[Music]
you